[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host Paul in this video we're
breaking down Ahsoka
episode 1 and 2 have just dropped online
and throughout this video we're going to
be breaking down the plot Easter eggs
hidden details and also giving our
theories on why we think the series will
be going I don't want to waste any of
your time so let's jump right into it
and begin with the red lucasfilm logo
and the character Poppins shown slowly
in red this changes for chapter two
where we get them adding blue in for
certain avatars this could show that
slowly hope is bleeding into the
universe and that we're gonna be
steering away from the more Dark Side
Centric colors at this first intro is
leaded with that also happened at the
start of the Mandalorian as well and
that was to highlight how things were
changing amongst them we get the combat
Droids that we meet throughout the
entries and can also spot the helmet of
marak in episode 2 Marik fights with an
inquisitor's blade showing how a lot of
the villainous stuff in this are
remnants of the Empire that plays off
massively in the second entry at the big
junk Factory which we'll talk more about
later on in the video I also have a
crazy Theory one of America that you can
probably guess off the thumbnail but
yeah going into that we're going to be
talking about that later on now timeline
wise this actually happens right after
the events of the Mandalorian season 2 a
soccer episode in which we saw her
arresting the magistrate and learning
more about thrawn in regards to Rebels
this is said to be the quote-unquote
fifth season of it and though it doesn't
pick up immediately after it it's
connected pretty closely to the events
of that we even get a sort of shot for
shot remake of the ending of the season
come episode 2 with Sabine touching
Ezra's mural before turning around to
see Ahsoka again it's sort of like
poetry they rhyme and it shows us how
this series is building off the back of
that now in case you need a quick catch
up on the ending of it it saw both Ezra
and thrawn being taken away by pergil
into unknown regions of the Galaxy we
ended the series with the group waiting
for an attack by the Empire but it never
came and we then got a time Jump to post
Battle of Endor Zeb and kallus ended up
going onto the secret hyperspace path
called Lira San and this was alongside
ancient kallus which is where they saw
the lasatron now thriving so actually
showed up in season three of the
Mandalorian and this might explain what
happened to him between this and that
now we discovered that Hera fought in
the Battle of endo alongside Rex and
that she actually had a son called Jason
though we don't see him in these two
entries in the Avatar bear we also get
Professor hu Yang from the Clone Wars
who's played by none other than David
Tennant now in addition to this there's
then Chopra and sabine's helmet which
then takes us into the first Star Wars
series title crawl rather than beginning
with the golden text that was common in
the Skywalker Saga we instead get read
to highlight the dark side that's
Central to the show this is kinda
similar to the final Arc of season 4 the
Clone Wars in which they swapped over to
a red title card and this was due to
Darth Maul being reintroduced and we
learned that though the new Republic
have provided peace there's still a plot
to find thrawn which would Galvanize the
Imperial remnants and then start another
War this is something that they kind of
touched upon in the Mandalorian with the
shadow cancel but as we know you know it
never comes to pass at least judging off
this sequel Trilogy now the last
paragraph talks about Ahsoka and it
kinda gives a lot of focus on the bit
about her being a former Jedi Knight
this is very important to pay attention
to as I feel like this series is gonna
be about her learning to embrace the
ways of the Jedi once more later on she
says she doesn't follow Jedi protocol
let's just say I didn't follow standard
Jedi protocol
this is kind of indicative of Anakin's
training and both balen and Shen Hadi
also play up the fact they're not Jedi
either we are no Jedi
I think this is a central idea to the
series as it comes into play with Sabine
2 and there's gonna be lots of force
sensitive characters carving out their
own paths in a time when both the
southern Jedi are at the lowest point my
guess is that Ahsoka will become one
come the end of the series and that
she'll go and help Luke set up his Doom
Training Academy that's gonna get
smashed like it's the like button
either way the title crawl also mentions
Morgan earlsbeth aka the magistrate from
season two of The Mandalorian back when
that episode dropped or editor Matt
actually followed it up with a theory
video on how Morgan L's Beth was
actually a night sister we get that
confirmed in these episodes so I'm
taking credit for that Matt you
literally twerking if you say anything
if you're fired in case you
don't know night sisters are kind of
witches that lived on dathomir and in
Jedi fall in order yeah actually ended
up teaming up with one there's lots of
subtle nuts to that game throughout both
of these entries and deep down I hope we
get a live action kalcaster showing up
one day I just don't know who I'd get to
play him though maybe maybe that lad who
plays running Harry Potter maybe maybe
but yeah drop drop your Carl kestus
perfect casting in the comments below
and I promise this isn't bait to get
more comments anyway the night sisters
are powerful mystical Warriors which
explains why the magistrate was able to
go toe-to-toe with Ahsoka now we
actually get lots of subtle nods to the
movies in this opening with us Beginning
by watching a ship coming in this is
similar to how A New Hope started and
there's lots of references to that early
on but of course honorable cruiser with
white interiors and both balen and Shane
are shot in a similar way to how Vader
entered the costumes are similar to The
Rebel forces in there and they get their
asses handed to them as well to
highlight the Empire's dominance now the
ship appears to be the precursor to the
radiss which was the main ship that the
rebels rode around on in The Last Jedi
in addition to this there's also clear
callbacks to both Return of the Jedi and
The Phantom Menace the shuttle arriving
is Akin's evader dropping in on the
death star with a rampant smoke echoing
how he made his entrance there's also
two Jedi type figures here which riffs
on Qui-Gon and Obi-Wan arriving at the
beginning of phantom menace now both
balen and shin are master and apprentice
and they do lots of subtle things with
them to highlight this fact bailin is
way more restrained with his use of the
dark side whereas Shin is aggressive and
quicker to go and fight this was
something we saw most notably with
Anakin and Obi-Wan as the former just
used to rush in the fights whereas the
ladder held back also might be reaching
but I thought the line we are no Jedi
was similar to
I am no Jedi now the captain arrives to
arrest them after realizing they're just
Imperial remnants but yeah not a great
player mate guessing Captain hell just
assumed these were disguised as Jedi and
couldn't actually wield the force but
yeah it's a bold strategy that that
doesn't really pay out now they kick the
crap out of them and while Shin savagely
busts them up Balin calmly walks through
the corridors killing the rebel forces
it's very reminiscent of the Vader
hallway scene from Rogue one with this
also being Meriden Luke's arrival in the
Mandalorian season 2 finale now sadly
Rey Stevenson who played Balin passed
away earlier this year and the guy
absolutely crushes it in this role which
makes it suck knowing that he died
before receiving all the love that he
would have got for this the episode
actually ends with a direct tribute to
him and it's really sad knowing this is
going to be such a big role for him that
he never got to see now Balin ends up
rescuing Morgan from his cell which
feels very reminiscent of Leia's rescue
in A New Hope Morgan tells him that
Ahsoka is now looking for a MacGuffin to
find thrawn and it's from here that we
then cut to the title sequence and one
thing I love about the score throughout
the Ahsoka bits are that it's clearly
based on Ancient Japanese music lots of
star Wars was based on things like
Hidden Fortress and kurosawa's films
which thematically pulls across to this
lone Samurai thing they have going on
the entry is also titled master and
Apprentice which ties in not only with
Balin and shin but also Ahsoka and
Sabine who will talk more about in just
a bit master and an apprentice
that would be my assumption we actually
joined Asoka arriving at a temple on
darkhana which our new host Mt pointed
out riffs a lot on zepho he noticed that
dotted throughout the area we have
figures that are holding astriums and
that their hand positions even reference
the one from the zeppo tombs theorizing
that these were an ancient alien race
that studied the force in the Galaxy the
man also brought up the triquetra which
appears throughout both episodes the
triquetra symbolizes a trinity and the
figures themselves may be another three
engine figures that were found on zepho
that was cujet ilaram and miktrel who
are slowly appearing more and more in
the law of Star Wars so I better learn
how to pronounce their names properly
and he's brought a hell of a lot to
these videos and I probably wouldn't
have spotted that without the guy's help
if you want to see the work he's done on
both Guardians of the Galaxy vol 3 and
across the spider-verse and they're
gonna be linked below so definitely
check them out he's also doing his own
big Ahsoka Theory video that's coming on
the channel very soon so keep an eye out
for that and make sure you subscribe
either way we learned this was the
night's sister Temple and at one point
they are referred to as witches episode
2 is actually called Thailand trouble
and this itself is a reference to the
witches from Macbeth now the inside of
the temples adorned with wall markings
and these somewhat make a return in the
credits to provide the art style of that
they kind of rip on the ones from Jedi
Survivor and also seem like a golden
version of the world Between Worlds in
Rebels season 4 episode 13 Ezra traveled
through a door out of this and it
carried similar markings had all kind of
tie this together it was at this world
Between Worlds that as he rescued Ahsoka
and her returning here is kind of
symbolic of her attempting to track down
both him and thrawn finally getting one
of the Golden Balls this again looks
like the ones from Fallen order and its
puzzle helps to unlock the unknown
knowledge now outside of the Tomb she's
ambushed by HK droids which I want to
say are the evolution of Magna Gods used
as handshomen by General Grievous in
Revenge of the Sith they also carry the
lightsaber blocking Electro staffs that
they did too upon being beat they decide
to self-destruct and this later later
causes a bit of a panic when they're
trying to hack one in episode 2.
and the whole scene reminded me a lot of
the opening of Raiders of the Lost Ark
with us getting a tomb before a big oh
just run out as fast as you can
scene also kind of riffs on the end of
Predator with defeat leading to
self-destruction and our hero basically
running to the channel like they've
heard empties doing videos rescued by hu
Yang he shows up an adhesive shuttle
which was an older Jedi form of
Transport put into increased circulation
during the Clone Wars later on we get
the full designation of it come in home
one this is
t61974 on approach which could be a no
to George Lucas right in the first
screenplay for a New Hope in 1974.
get a radio message
the code name fulcrum being summing at
Ahsoka used throughout Star Wars Rebels
learning of the prison transport attack
we see X-Wing in a new Republic Cruiser
investigating it and can see that it's
completely up the ship landing on
board the cruiser she then reunited with
General Hera who's played by none other
than Mary Elizabeth Winstead and she
kinda has a connection to Star Wars
already as her husband's actually you
and McGregor AKA Obi-Wan Kenobi
hello there
hello there on the back of a jacket we
can spot the Specter symbol as well and
this was something that was part of the
ghost crew there's also the star bit on
her arm and we know from the episode
center around her that this was part of
her family crest looks actually base the
Imperial and rebel logos of Japanese
family crests and this was kind of
carried over for heras as well now
watching back and recording of Balin and
Shane it kind of reminded me of the
Hologram of Anakin cutting up
six-year-olds at the Jedi Temple which
to be fair the the kids deserved at me
he had a lightsaber he was a
self-defense Ahsoka tells us the globe
tells the position of the last grand
Admiral AKA thrawn which hero Buffs as
being impossible believing he died at
the Battle of lothal that was the one in
which the peer girl took him and Ezra
out of there we can also see some
calamari commanders and as a species
they became high-ranking ones amongst
the rebels in their four New Republic
realizing they need to figure out how
the globe Works they then head out to
lothal to seek out Sabine Sabine and
Ahsoka made a promise to find Ezra at
the end of rebels but as we learned
things didn't go that smoothly honestly
one of the criticisms I have of this
show and lucasfilm stuff in general is
that they tend to leave the characters
on a positive high now and then when
they bring them back they're in the
opposite place of what they were this is
just seems to me like they just do to
cause some dramatic tension and all this
stuff it always happens off screen this
was the case with both Luke and Indiana
Jones as well and it's kind of weird
giving us a shot for shot remake of the
ending of rebels when they could have
just hit the ground running from that
point instead of taking two hours to get
back to it it's a nitpick I understand
I'm going off going off tangent there
but it was obvious that we were going to
end up back where we started so it made
it feel a bit Meandering anyway nitpick
aside they go to Sabine and this is
because of how smart he is as an
archaeologist she was the one who
translated the lothal runes and in the
end she helped to free the planet now
the monument still stands strong and we
join a celebrate Asian for the victory
of the battle of lothal which is headed
up by Ryder Azadi played by Clancy Brown
he's now doing the character he voiced
in live action however this isn't the
only live-action Star Wars role that the
ACT has been a part of he actually
showed up in season one of the
Mandalorian as Berg and ironically that
was to do with the prison escape episode
we see his cam droids film the entire
thing and these also come from the
expanded law now behind him is the mural
for Ezra which depicts the crew of the
ghost along with those two giant lothal
wolves white and black Mt was saying
these could potentially depict the light
and dark side of the force which is
something that could be connected to
Ezra either way it's a perfect
Recreation of the one from the series
with it even carrying across the
animated style that was used for that
Sabine was supposed to be giving a
speech there but we finally doing our
best Akira impression on top of a
Speeder Bike listening to Punky Japanese
style music this was something that
appeared in Rebels and her passion for
customizing her stuff can also be seen
here too on a helmet we can catch a
drawing of a Loth cat and she's also
wearing one of Hera's jackets who
watches she runs rings around the
security forces that have been ordered
to take her in and it's clear that there
no one's a real match for her now she's
living in the lothal communication Tower
which fans and Rebels will instantly
recognize this location was a hangout of
Ezra before he joined ghost and we can
also catch some little things to make at
home there's a lot of cat murals to them
and Stormtrooper helmets with crosses on
them showing how many Sabine took down
dotted around the room about storm and
scout trooper helmets and we also have
her Mandalorian armor hidden away
symbolizing how she's turned her back on
it Sabine was originally the one who
handed the darksaber over the bow Katan
but she's no longer with them and is
kind of like a long gun she was trained
as a Jedi but both Kanan and Ezra sensed
that she wasn't actually Force sensitive
now in her belongings we can also catch
another of Hera's patches and Sabine
actually took this in Rebels Len used it
as part of her armor still pining for
Ezra we can also see that she carries a
holographic message for him similar to
the one that he left everyone at the end
of rebels as she sits down and watches
it we can also catch a wolf drawn onto
the wall and she's kind of just existing
instead of living from here we go to the
knight's sister Temple and it's at this
point that we're also introduced to
maroc marak actually has some ties to
the expanded law and the Bounty Hunter
embo actually had a pet wolf that
carried the name the name itself
actually comes from Sir Mark of the
Round Table who was an eyed of Arthurian
legend in the tales Marek was turned
into a wolf by a witch which is where he
continued to serve the realm in his
Beast form now it's your time
one one moment in time
so obviously we don't know who Marek is
but they're a keen Force sensitive
character who's got leanings of the dark
side I actually think it would be pretty
wild if this turned out to be Ezra and
that's why the character is wearing a
mask Morgan is a witch and she may have
turned Ezra into a quote unquelf Wolf by
corrupting him through the east of the
dark side Ezra was also close to the
Loth wolves potentially handing out why
he now carries his name could be a big
reveal down the line but yeah if it's
not me it's just a few times due time if
it's not going to be taken serious you
dumb it's that you can't say I'm
wrong okay we can but it's just opinion
One Moment In Time
now we've also just launched in a circle
and grago inspired t-shirt over our
merch store below which is it's just
below the video all of our few time Pulp
Fiction and Marvel and Spider-Man just
down there and it's the best way to help
support the channel anyway we cut back
to Sabine I can catch you having a sort
of full stream about Ezra a welcome by
an alarm she then steps out of the Tower
and we get a shot that Echoes the ending
of rebels that had to be leaning on the
railing of the Tower and she watched the
T6 fly overhead with x-wings escorting
it that happens here too and it's meant
to bring things full circle from the
last time we saw Sabine in Ahsoka Sabine
goes back on the ship and Asoka goes off
to take a dump I think and we see Sabine
spared on the T6 from her training this
contains sketches of Loth cats like her
bed in the tower as well as Tie fighters
and the Droid Chopper we get some of the
tension between the pair playing out
with Sabine calling Ahsoka Jedi and them
both blaming each other for their failed
relationship the professor also talks
about Balin being a Jedi that does
appeared after the Clone Wars any hints
at Ahsoka is gonna need help to tackle
him and also his Apprentice Shin
guessing that he was trained there as a
youngling and apprentice and he does
touch upon this later on in episode 2.
The Children of the Jedi Temple called
it that comes from old stories if he was
one of those kids this is where he'd
have heard it and it's a nice line that
kind of paints at his backstory yours to
get a little hint that he hasn't found
Luke yet as you can kinda take her
thinking she's the only Jedi out there
other than these two running off with
the ball we also watches sabina's stock
by Shin's probe Droid which is very
reminiscent of Darth Maul's probes on
Tatooine
[Music]
back with a soccer and Hera we get some
lip service pay to a sucker walking away
from her master Anakin and also the Jedi
seeing herself as walking away from
Sabine she just basically thinks she's a
failure and very much seems like she
wants to write these wrongs but it isn't
smooth sailing and we watches sabine's
Ambush by Shin after solving the puzzle
this all happens because Sabine goes
against ahsoka's orders which might make
her think that she needs to listen to
her more I'm guessing the pair fell out
because both refuse to listen to the
other and you can kind of see that they
start to mend their Bridges this puts
Sabine in a really bad position though
and she has to burst out her lightsaber
once more now we learned that this is
actually Ezra's second lightsaber which
we saw him using throughout most of
rebels though she puts up a fight
sabine's best it pretty easily stabbing
left for dead which is where we close
out the episode now she's one of the
only people who's ever survived a
lightsaber wound like this and it kind
of puts a vendetta against her and shin
can kind of Imagine qui-gon's Force
ghost just seeing another person survive
this and and starting off and being like
you damn son of a either way I
really enjoyed their fight and though
episode one had some dips in terms of
pacing I think on the whole it worked
pretty well there was a lot of
atmosphere to it and all this stuff with
shin and balen really took this above
just being more mundane Star Wars now
Ahsoka arrives to stop her from dealing
a killing blow and that then takes us
into episode 2 beginning with A Silva
lucasfilm logo as opposed to the red one
from the first episode we also see as
the Star Wars logo has switched to gold
too echoing Luke's loss at the end of
Empire we see as sabines fixed up by a
medical Droid but it also appears she's
more in tune with the force Ahsoka seems
to be able to hear her thoughts and I
think she's clearly starting to tap into
things that she hasn't been able to
before later on the professor gives her
a bit of a demotivational talk and he
puts the idea in her head that she needs
to embrace her training he basically
says she should do it even if a circle
is in there and if a Circa goes off to
be with Luke I think sabine's still
gonna continue it now I love how Osaka
concerns she's about having Nightmare
and just before this happened she then
wakes her up this is because Viking
Cloud one's mind in a dream and Anakin
was of course put on the path to the
dark side due to his nightmares of Padme
now I don't know if it's been growing
Force sensitive is gonna annoy people
because typically you're either Force
sensitive or you're not oh I and this is
my head kind of yeah I always thought
people like Han Solo yet as they became
more aware of it they they didn't
necessarily tap into it but they became
stronger do you know this and and this
is why he was such a good pilot and
fighter what do you mean you've turned
the video off now what I'm saying is is
that basically if if you if you think
hard enough mate you you yourself you
can become a Jedi Knight and the thumbs
Up's right there Force push it now
that's kind of what I see happening with
Sabine and we watches bailing and shin
me elves both at a religious Shrine like
the one from typhoon Amanda known as a
reflex point this gives them knowledge
of how to find Throne which is where we
close things out at the end of the entry
I love the way their ship is shot from
behind once more and this Echoes its
arrival at the start of the first
episode later on Morgan puts a pawn into
the architecture Circle and this sort of
acts like its own star map now she
lights us up using a green flame which
is something that the Knight sisters
were also able to conjure this lights up
a pathway to boredia which the knight's
sister says go Us by another name now
this potentially indicates that it holds
another Temple layer and we see as
Morgan can tap directly into messages
from thrawn got lots of Vibes and
writers of the Lost stock as well and
how the staff of Rao had to be put in a
certain place for the sunlight to guide
the way that's sort of what happens yeah
and the Hologram Globe also reminded me
a lot of Prometheus which is of course
now also owned by Disney now you can
catch per girl on the map as well
indicating we might see them more as we
get further into the series grogu
actually spotted one in a hyperspace
Lane Amano season 3 so I can imagine
we'll get them further expanded upon
they also mention the eye of Sion which
we see at the end of the entry and this
could potentially be named after Darth
Sion known as the Lord of pain this is
an ancient dark lord who comes from the
time of the Sith Lord War balen says
that thrawn will bring them more power
more than they've ever imagined but I
think it goes beyond what we consider it
to be if there's a temple at the other
side this could open up and tap
knowledge and help them to land things
that they never would have without it
ourselka does some investigating at
sabines and turning on Force detective
mode she picks up Force Echoes this was
something that too appeared in the Jedi
games with calling countering them as
sort of Collectibles that filled in the
history of an area she also sees
Esther's hologram before being attacked
by a Droid and this is the mind that
they hack into sort of like a hacking
game and they break into its brain kinda
like how they did with C3PO in Rise of
Skywalker now we discover the Droid came
from a new Republic Shipyard on corellia
which was actually the home of Han Solo
it's very gray and dour and it's sort of
got this machine like quality to the
entire thing in Mando season 3 we
discover the new Republic with
dismantling Imperial staff and it's sort
of a carryover from that with them
apparently doing the same thing
junkyards like this have appeared in The
Saga before with us also seeing one on
Brach are at the start of falling order
is to appeared in the bad batch and the
the sparkling nice glow over here shows
the difference between the two sites the
new Republic's dismantling is clean and
professional looking whereas the
Imperials had it like a desolate
graveyard here we meet Min Weaver who's
in a sort of similar role to Tim Meadows
Colonel Tuttle but that he's a private
businessman who shows as Imperials at
every level which was something that the
Mandalorian also touched upon too we
learn he's part of them as well and the
first clue that he's in cahoots comes
when he refuses a direct order from Hera
even though she's a general the new
Republic defense Fleet is mentioned as
well and this is basically the new
Republic's version of a Navy here we
also learn that Ahsoka abandoned Sabine
and she's sum up mensaways later on by
going to help Luke's training of grogu I
also feel like Sabine self-doubt held
her back but embracing her training once
more might push it forward now we
learned that though most of the ships
have been destroyed that they actually
have a hyperdrive from a superstar
Destroyer Ahsoka also brings up the HK
droids again AKA Hunter Killers which
are what we learn have been used by
Morgan the pro local Droid snitches and
says that she spotted one which is when
the Imperials play their hand whilst the
engine gets taken out of there on the
ground Asoka goes tonito with Marek
while we see hair attack to the skies
riding in the Phantom now this was a
hidden ship on the back of the ghost and
they'd often pilot it when doing Special
side missions alongside of this Chopper
who gets to makes a big entrance and he
he adds a tracking device to the
hyperdrive so that they can follow it oh
I love the way that Mark escapes only
causes lightsaber back to him and
rewatches Ahsoka just calmly Dodges out
the way back with Sabine we see as she
cuts her hair short making her more
closely aligned with how she was in
Rebels we also see she gets her armor
out and can again catch a poor girl
sitting on a shoulder pad focusing on
her Mandalorian helmet it is possible
that she may become a Mandalorian Jedi
and this would be similar to the path
that grogu's on I wouldn't be surprised
if she showed up in Mando at some point
and potentially she'll be reunited with
Beau for the next part we then get a
shot for shot remake of the ending of
rebels with with Sabine going out of the
mural and touching Ezra's face upon
turning around she sees Ahsoka has
arrived and this brings things full
circle from that again kinda feel like
we spent two hours just to get back to
that point but yeah let me know all your
thoughts below now tracing the tracking
device they then head out with a soccer
calling Sabine her Padawan from here we
jump to the eye of Scion to see the
hyperdrive being dropped off and this is
a jump point that that sort of shot up
in the Saga quite a lot feels like it's
sort of The Next Step Up from the one
that the Jedi Knights had during the
Clone Wars and their starfighters would
of course darken these and then head out
bailing clearly shows his conflict as he
States there's so few Jedi left and it
would be a shame to lose more in
clashing with Ahsoka now we end with the
station almost being completed and I'm
guessing the next episode that'll be
finished off before they head out
looking for thrawn now before we get
into the review I want to talk about the
images of thrawn from the trailer so if
you don't want to have anything
potentially spoiled then skip ahead now
out you still here okay well in the
teaser we see him standing not only on
the eye of cyan but also in a room that
shows a world within World markings
guessing that he'll be at a temple too
and that's how they'll connect and the
hyperdrive thing will lead directly to
him also when adding this bit into the
video I realized that if maroc is Ezra
then it explains why he has to use an
inquisitor's lightsaber as Sabine has
his either way it closes out these very
first two episodes without finally
feeling like things are now gonna get
going and that's kind of where I'm at
with the series going off these first
two episodes alone there were parts that
I really liked but on the whole it just
kind of felt like they were setting
things up rather than fully delivering
on what I wanted to see emotionally I
feel like all the characters seem
distant and I found it a bit difficult
to connect with them they weren't the
more light-hearted and charismatic ones
agreed to love in Rebels and instead I I
don't know I just felt they seemed a bit
stuck I'm not damning the show just yet
but I can totally see why they're
released two episodes at once pacing
wise it was kind of all over the place
where there being lots of slow moments
and then I'm just dropping in the odd
action scene to try and keep people's
interests it's still early days but yeah
I thought this was a bit hit and miss uh
though I know I'm in the minority
judging off the reviews always kind of
feel bad saying I wasn't enamored with
something as I know you guys probably
want someone really enthusiastic about a
show bringing you breakdowns on it it
was fine but yeah I'm hoping for a bit
more and maybe next week now the setup's
out the way we can really get into it
now as you probably know the release
time has changed and we're going to be
getting episodes at 2AM UK time I'm
gonna wake up just normal time next week
and see how we get on in terms of
releasing a video slightly later and how
much it affects the views but I'd kind
of feel bad telling all the team to get
up in the middle of the night for videos
when you know they've got families and
stuff so yeah probably dropping our
breakdowns early morning on the
Wednesday but keep an eye out for it if
you enjoyed this one please drop a like
on the video if you did and if you want
to support the channel as a member of
the spoiler Society then please click
the join button it helps all these
videos get made keeps a roof over our
head lets us be independent and it goes
such a long way to helping us out as a
thank you you'll get early access to
videos every week and yeah hopefully all
the members who've signed up are
enjoying the the early content now if
you want something else to watch you've
got a breakdown of a new Hub on screen
right now which I guarantee you even if
you've seen that movie A Thousand Times
which you probably have there's gonna be
something in there that you haven't
noticed before we're really proud of the
video it's one of the best on the
channel and hopefully I see you over
there right after this by the way I've
been your host Paul you've been the best
and I'll see you next time take care
peace